bonjour à tous
donc aujourd'hui je sais que la course à
pied très à la mode dont je vous invite
vous inviter à venir courir avec moi
avant de vous précipiter pour dire oui
je vais quand même vous préciser un
petit peu comment va fonctionner donc
évidemment vous avez déjà un petit peu
vendu le punch paiera falloir courir
matin et soir 10 km il ya probablement
un petit peu moins de personnes qui vont
être intéressés maintenant je vais vous
dire qu'il va falloir le faire cinq fois
par semaine je vais faire dix fois par
non cinq fois l'aller-retour par semaine
donc ça va être dix courses par semaine
10 x 10 km 100 km après on demande
souvent mais ce qui va vraiment falloir
y aller quand il pleut oui quand il
neige oui quand il fait moins 20 oui
absolument
quand il fait plus 20 + 30 oui tous les
jours donc ça c'est pourtant exactement
ce que je fais depuis maintenant quatre
ans matin et soir tous les jours de la
semaine pour me rendre au travail et en
revenir
pourquoi est-ce que je m'impose
finalement c'est aller retour parce que
j'ai une passion qui s'appelle des
ultramarathons les ultra marathon ce
sont ces genres de courses qui font plus
que le marathon traditionnel
le marathon traditionnel c'est 42,2 km
n'importe quoi de plus long ça s'appelle
un ultramarathon habituellement les gens
font leur entrée dans l'ultra marathon
quand ils font 50 km ceux qui sont un
petit peu plus confirmés vont à 80 km et
moi dans mon cas comme des centaines
d'autres je me spécialise dans les
courses de 160 km
c'est une spécialité alors évidemment
vous imaginez bien que pour courir 60
kilomètres ça ne se fait pas du jour au
lendemain il faut s'entraîner énormément
dans ce cas là j'ai un petit problème
qui est le problème en fait de bien du
monde sait que je suis mariée j'ai pas
un problème
j'ai trois enfants c'est pas un problème
non plus sauf que ça prend beaucoup de
temps et la fatigue énormément donc
avant je courrais déjà mais quand il a
fallu que je continue à m'entraîner pour
les ultra marathon avec trois jeunes
enfants à la maison donc 7 ans 6 ans et
4 ans ça c'est maintenant il était
beaucoup plus jeune quand j'ai commencé
ce n'était tout simplement pas possible
j'ai essayé de trouver des solutions
j'ai tout essayé j'ai essayé de
commencer par exemple en me levant très
tôt le matin 4h30 le matin en centre est
très courageux on sort il fait nuit il
fait très froid
on va courir on est très content quand
on revient j'ai tenu trois mois j'ai
abandonné au bout de trois mois j'étais
crevé ça ne servait à rien ensuite
j'essaie et le soir en fait pour être
honnête j'ai jamais si elle soit trop
fatigué aussi après je me suis tourné
vers l'or sur l'heure du lunch au
travail pourquoi pas ça fonctionne tant
qu'on court une heure quand on court 30
km sur l'heure du lunch lors du lunch
devient les trois heures du l'âge ça
pose des problèmes au travail
donc j'avais plus à peu près toutes les
options sauf celle de la fin de semaine
devant la fin de semaine
la famille des enfants etc j'ai oublié
ça donc par élimination je suis dit ben
qu'est ce qui me reste
et là tout d'un coup j'ai réalisé même
ça fait plusieurs années que je
travaille au même endroit et que
j'habite au même endroit que la distance
entre la maison et le travail faisait 10
km 10 km alors que je courais déjà
depuis plusieurs années dont je savais
que je pouvais faire la distance après
enchaîné 10 km matin et soir
ça c'était la grande question me suis
dit bon de façon j'ai pas vraiment
d'autre option il faut que je me lance
donc je me suis lancée du jour au
lendemain je l'ait décidé finalement de
transformer mon entraînement en
transport est ce que je n'ai pas du tout
vu venir en faisant ce set ce changement
là c'est tout d'un coup mais course
finalement se sont transformés en
exploration quotidienne laissez moi vous
expliquer car comme tout le monde
oui je l'aï si je cours j'ai besoin de
mes clés et non téléphone donc armé de
mes jambes et de mon téléphone je pars
au travail donc par exemple c'était il
ya quelques années au mois de septembre
donc je courais tranquillement je
partais de la russule de longueuil de
montréal en prenant le pont
jacques-cartier pour passer au dessus du
fleuve saint laurent
le trajet que je fais tous les jours
mais je n'ai toujours un coup d'oeil à
droite et à gauche
effectivement tout d'un coup sur la
gauche je vois un nuage un nuage blanc
devait venir un nuage blanc
pas très original sauf que le nuage
était pas en l'air il était posé sur le
fleuve une cage le regard josias est
intéressant et il semblait venir vers
moi légèrement poussé par le vent donc
là j'ai continué ma course
tranquillement en surveillant ce nuage
et puis effectivement un moment nous sur
tourneur en arrivant au milieu du pont
et j'ai pris cette photo
tout d'un coup le pont avait
complètement disparu où il est sorti mon
appareil photo le pont avait
complètement disparu
on voyait plus la ville on voyait plus
le fleuve on voyait plus rien donc si
j'avais été en voiture à ce moment là si
j'avais son âge il choisi un mode de
transport finalement assez classique ça
aurait été juste une nappe de brouillard
et j'aurais juste été fixées sur le pare
choc de la voiture en avant pour être
sûr de pas rentrer dedans là par contre
j'ai pu profiter du spectacle et j'ai
bien fait de le faire parce que 30
secondes après le nuage avait disparu le
soleil était ressorti on avait un beau
ciel bleu donc cette fois ci j'ai eu la
chance d'être exactement au bon endroit
au bon moment
donc des chances comme ça j'en ai eu pas
mal mais en fait quand on y pense
est ce que c'est vraiment de la chance
parce qu'on n'y allons matin et soir
matin et soir il ya plein de choses que
j'ai raté évidemment il ya plein de
choses que je n'ai pas vu il ya bien des
choses que j'ai vues et gtpob un endroit
pour prendre la photo vous dire ça
aurait pu être beau mais je n'y étais
pas cette fois ci j étais donc c'était
de la chance par contre d'autres fois
j'ai c'est de provoquer la chance
pourquoi parce que je sais exactement où
je m'en vais je connais parfaitement en
environnement je sais quelle heure le
soleil se lève à quelle heure le soleil
se couche comment peut jouer la lumière
en fonction de la fonction de l' instant
de la journée
parce que je passe là tous les jours et
je sais exactement ce qui m'attend donc
une fois de temps en temps j'essaie
d'aller chercher une photo je vais
véritablement la chasse aux photos comme
cette fois donc là on est en plein mois
de février il fait moins
- 25 extrêmement froid pour une fois je
me dis je vais partir un petit peu plus
tôt du travail parce que le matin
j'avais repéré il ya un chenal au milieu
du fleuve saint laurent entre l'île
sainte-hélène et l'île notre dame qui
est complètement pris par les glaces
il est complètement bloqués sauf que ce
n'est pas une belle patinoire c'est des
blocs de glace qui sont tous les uns sur
les autres
j'avais juste à le matin la lumière
était pas belle ne dit peut-être que ce
soir avec le soleil couchant ce serait
intéressant mais encore fallait-il que
j'arrive à temps donc je suis parti du
travail un tout petit peu plus tôt parce
que je savais qu'il fallait une demi
heure pour quitter le travail arriver
jusqu'à l'île sainte-hélène descendre la
berge qui était entièrement recouverte
de neige me placer exactement d'un
endroit
et vu qu'il faisait moins 20 pas
attendre la 20 minute
en attendant que le soleil se couche il
fallait que j'arrive exactement au bon
moment donc en connaissant exactement
tout ça je suis arrivé exactement bon
moment et j'ai pu prendre cette photo
donc cette image je suis allé la
chercher
si j'y étais allé le lendemain c'était
trop tard le lendemain pourquoi parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de soleil il y avait
des nuages qui était allé deux jours
après quand il un nouveau soleil ça ne
fonctionnaient plus non plus la neige
était tombée à laver recouvert les blocs
de glace on ne voyait plus rien donc
cette photo je suis vraiment allé la
chercher
mais si je voulais parlement que cet
hiver en cherchant un petit peu je
pourrais arriver à la referme ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la photo suivante
dont je vais vous parler la photo
suivante je peux vous garantir ça fait
1600 fois que je fais mon allée et mon
retour en quatre ans je pourrais le
faire pendant encore quatre ans je
pourrais faire pendant encore 40 ans la
photo suivante je ne pourrai jamais la
reprendre pourquoi très simple je
quittais le travail toutes les histoires
commencé comme ça quitte la maison je
quitte le train
je quittais le travail beau coucher de
soleil donc là je commence à jeter un
coup d'oeil coucher de soleil la lumière
beau coucher de soleil sur le
centre-ville de montréal
encore une fois m février mois de
février très photogénique pénible mais
photogénique bon mois de février les
immeubles fume et à coucher de soleil
le vieux port est entièrement gelé là
par contre une vraie patinoire tout
lisse tout blanc superbe là je regardais
a fait quelque chose qui bouge et un
brise glace qui est en train de dégager
la glace au complet médias n'en voit pas
souvent c'est intéressant mais ça je
peux ressortir n'est pas besoin de
sortir 1600 x pour voir 1re classe
par contre en ralentissant pour voir si
ça ferait une belle photo et là tout
d'un coup il ya quelque chose qui attire
mon attention
d'un coup il ya un point orange orange
vif qui sur la glace là je m'arrête pour
bien comprendre ce que c'est c'est est
un renard un renard en train de courir
sur la glace et de mon point de vue on
aurait l'impression avait l'impression
qui faisait la course avec le
brise-glace donc la photo la voix si je
savais pertinemment qu'avec mon
téléphone
ça ne servait à rien de prendre cette
photo donc plutôt que de sortir mon
téléphone ne me précipiter avec les
mitaines effet moins 1 tapez le code
prendre une mauvaise photo et ne rien
voir
j'ai préféré laisser le téléphone là où
il était passé dix secondes à regarder
le renard courir à disparaître et avoir
cette image en tête maintenant je suis
sûr que vous l'avez également
les photos comme ça à force d'accumuler
des sorties maintenant j'en ai des
centaines donc j'ai le plaisir à me fait
juste et beau en plus c'est qu'à chaque
fois je pars pour le matin au travail et
je n'ai aucune idée de ce qui m'attend
c'est vraiment un univers que je
découvre à chaque fois ces photos là je
les partage donc sur instagram et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une surprise
renouvelé la magie tout ça c'est que
finalement je suis toujours content
d'aller au travail de partir pour le
travail arrivé au travail
on en rediscutera partir au travail
c'est un plaisir sans cesse renouvelé
le plus drôle c'est que c'est censé être
mon entraînement mais je me souviens
même pas que c'est un entraînement parce
que moi je ne fais juste partir que pour
prendre des photos il se trouve
seulement aux transports il se trouve
que ces mots l'entraînement alors est ce
que ça fonctionne dans les 12 derniers
mois pour les ultra marathon parce que
c'est quand même pour ça que j'ai
commencé à faire ça à l'origine des 12
derniers mois
j'ai fini sur le podium à 165km au
virgin il ya douze mois
j'ai traversé la martinique au complet
135 km donc j'ai traversé du nord au sud
de la martinique et j'ai couru les 60
derniers kilomètres
main dans la main pour traverser ligne
d'arrivée main dans la main avec un
rasta qu'on a ensuite invité à venir au
québec
ça c'est le genre de rencontre qui ne se
remplace pas il ya juste quelques mois
j'ai fait tour du massif du mont-blanc
170 km donc ce parcours m'a pris 33
heures et deux minutes tout sans prendre
des photos comme base d'entraînement
deux semaines après le mont blanc je
prenais le train de montréal pour venir
à québec et je suis reparti à pied j'ai
couru de québec à montréal en une traite
250 km il m'a fallu 30 et 1h30
quelques semaines après québec montréal
je suis allé sur l'île de la réunion île
de la réunion 165 km une île volcanique
celle ci est un petit peu long du mât
fallu quarante deux heures et 43 minutes
pour en arriver au bout tout ça
finalement
en prenant des photos parce que c'est la
base de mon entraînement je veux travail
en prenant des photos et c'est pas tout
car en partageant les photos avant
j'avais commencé un blog le blog avait
finalement donné également une vidéo
cette vidéo était devenue virale ensuite
tué les photos et la prochainement je
vais rassembler mes textes et mes photos
pour publier un livre
pourquoi parce qu'à un moment entre la
métro entre le métro le vélo la voiture
j'ai plutôt choisi de courir j'ai
finalement choisi de prendre une autre
direction
merci